L'apôtre Paul ici est en train d'évoquer les fruits de l'esprit, un fruit singulier qui possède plusieurs facettes.
Et la considération du fruit de l'esprit est dans un contexte où Paul est en train de traiter une dimension du phénomène qu'est la vie chrétienne,
qui est un croyant, qui est la conversion, qu'on a l'habitude d'appeler la sanctification.
La lettre de Paul au Galate, elle est concentrée sur deux vérités principales qui sont toujours inséparables.
Comment les saluts d'une personne a lieu, comment une personne est réconciliée avec Dieu, comment elle peut être née de nouveau.
Et le langage central, c'est la justice.
On sait très bien que les problèmes fondamentaux de l'être humain, c'est le manque de justice devant Dieu, sans, absolument sans.
Ce manque de justice met l'homme dans une position de condamnation, ce qui devrait nous rendre désespérés.
Mais elle débase aussi l'être humain, car on a été créé à l'origine pour nous satisfaire en accomplissant les buts de notre existence.
Et en tant qu'image de Dieu, l'être humain est satisfait lorsque sa conscience ne peut pas l'accuser.
Lorsqu'il a la capacité de vivre la vie que Dieu vit, vivre une vie d'amour, des joies, qui est liée à cette notion de justice.
Donc les deux emphases principales en termes de justice et salut, qui est Paul traite dans sa lettre,
ce sont ces deux dimensions séparables.
La justification en termes des déclarations.
Et de l'autre côté, le fait qu'il est chrétien, quelqu'un qui sera rendu juste.
Déclaré juste d'un côté, rendu juste de l'autre côté.
Nous sommes déclarés justes.
Lorsqu'il part la foi, nous embrassons les crises comme notre représentant devant les tribunaux de Dieu,
car aucun être humain n'a la capacité de vivre une vie parfaite, d'amour, de joie, de paix, de bénignité, etc., de justice.
Et comme nous n'avons pas la capacité de présenter à Dieu une justice propre, par nos propres efforts, par nos efforts religieux,
nous avons besoin d'un substitut parfait.
Dieu envoie Christ, il accomplit parfaitement la loi à notre place, il vit la vie parfaite qui personne ne vit.
Et par la foi, nous embrassons ces représentants légaux devant les tribunaux de Dieu.
Si par la foi nous sommes unis à Christ,
Dieu nous met dans une position de justice parfaite d'une fois pour toutes.
Il n'y a aucun acte que l'être humain puisse faire s'il est un Christ,
qu'il puisse ajouter justice à son comportement,
et aucun acte qu'il puisse faire
qu'il puisse décroître ou diminuer
sa position de justice devant Dieu.
Même nos péchés après notre conversion
n'ont pas la capacité de diminuer cette position que nous avons devant Dieu.
Pourquoi ?
Car un Christ, nous sommes pleinement sans.
C'est une union légale
par laquelle la justice du Christ nous est amputée.
Son comportement parfait
et sa punition à la croix.
Si par la foi nous sommes unis à Christ,
tous nos péchés passés, présents, futurs
ont déjà été punis en Christ, à la croix.
Et tous les comportements parfaits du Christ nous ont crédités.
Les chrétiens peuvent avoir la absolue paix
d'une fois pour toutes déclarées devant les tribunaux de Dieu
comme justes.
Position, ok ?
Sauf que pour ceux qui sont véritablement convertis,
cette position devant Dieu
n'est pas qu'une position détachée
de sa nouvelle vie.
car au même temps
que devant les tribunaux légaux de Dieu
on est associés à Christ,
cette union avec Christ
n'est pas qu'une union juridique, légale.
Elle est aussi une union qu'on appelle vitale.
Ceux qui sont en Christ
n'ont pas été tout simplement déclarés
enfants de Dieu,
ils ont été faits enfants de Dieu.
Ils sont nés de nouveau,
nés pour Dieu,
unis à Christ.
La différence c'est que quand on pense
à la conversion,
être déclaré juste,
on a changé des positions d'une fois pour toutes.
Lorsque nous sommes faits justes,
nés de nouveau,
c'est cette autre dimension,
la régénération,
c'est-à-dire la renaissance spirituelle,
est une réalité radicale,
certaine.
c'est une transformation
tellement puissante
que nous sommes appelés
une nouvelle créature
avec une nouvelle volonté.
Sauf que cette nouvelle créature
avec une nouvelle volonté,
même si c'est assuré
qu'elle progressera
dans sa sanctification,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle sera
chaque fois plus juste
dans l'expérience
et dans la pratique,
ce n'est pas une œuvre,
une œuvre faite
complètement
d'une fois pour toutes
au moment de notre conversion.
On fait la distinction
entre conversion
et sanctification.
À la conversion,
nous sommes déclarés
juste d'une fois pour toutes.
Ça ne va changer jamais.
Sauf que tous ceux
qui ont été convertis
véritablement
vont progresser
en sanctité.
Donc la vie chrétienne
est présentée par l'apôtre Paul
comme une bataille.
L'illustration,
c'est la bataille
de l'agriculture
où nous avons
une nouvelle volonté
aidée par la troisième
personne de la Trinité,
le Saint-Esprit,
c'est qu'il nous assure
que cette nouvelle identité
va inévitablement
sortir victorieuse
dans les longs termes
de notre vie chrétienne.
par contre,
il y a encore
les restes de la chair.
Et les restes de la chair,
c'est cet ennemi intérieur,
nous avons beaucoup
d'ennemis extérieurs,
les mondes,
Satan,
les non-chrétiens,
mais la réalité,
c'est que notre plus grand
ennemi,
c'est la chair
à l'intérieur.
Car même
ces ennemis
de l'extérieur
se font valoir
de cet ennemi
intérieur.
Pour que nous
ne manifestions pas
ce qui nous sommes
véritablement
notre nouvelle nature.
Pour que nous ne fassions pas
ce qui est
la volonté
la plus profonde
du croyant.
Manifester Christ,
manifester
les fruits de l'esprit.
Dans cette bataille
d'agriculture,
donc,
il y a une guerre
réelle.
la victoire
est assurée,
mais nous devons
être conscients
que cet ennemi
intérieur,
même s'il a déjà
souffert un coup
mortel,
verset 24,
ceux qui sont
Jésus-Christ
ont déjà crucifié
la chair
avec ses passions,
un coup mortel,
mais elle manifeste
encore des forces
qui s'opposent
à la direction
de notre nouvelle vie.
L'objectif
de l'apôtre Paul
dans ses passages,
quand il mention
les fruits de l'esprit,
c'est de redresser
une église
en crise.
Et il va redresser
cette église
sur une base
d'assurance
certaine
par rapport
à eux.
Paul n'a qu'à
l'espoir
que les galaxies
se laissent corriger,
qu'ils reviennent
à manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
car il est
convaincu
de leur conversion.
Car,
à un moment donné
dans leur vie,
ils ont déjà
manifesté
avec plein d'évidence
les fruits de l'esprit.
Les moments
où Paul a implanté
cette église,
c'était évident
qu'ils étaient
scellés par les
saints-esprits
et qu'ils ont
changé de vie.
Et ce qui est
intéressant ici,
c'est que Paul
ne va pas présenter
la manière
de corriger
cette église
comme s'il
devrait recommencer
la foi,
comme s'ils avaient
perdu les saluts
et qu'ils
devraient restaurer.
l'exhortation
à manifester
les fruits
de l'esprit
au Galacte
est sur la base
du présupposé
qu'ils sont déjà
l'habitation
de son esprit.
Car ce n'est pas
un fruit
qui puisse opérer
d'eux-mêmes,
c'est un fruit
de l'esprit
qui ne peut
qu'être opéré
par l'esprit
lui-même.
Donc,
ce que nous
en tant que chrétiens
devons retenir
devant les oscillations
de nos vies,
c'est que si nous sommes
véritablement chrétiens,
c'est beaucoup
plus important
de prendre conscience
de ce qui nous sommes
et comment
le Saint-Esprit
opère envers
notre sanctification
que des pensées
que nous sommes ici
devant des conditions
pour maintenir
les saluts
ou pour reconquérir
les saluts.
Le fruit
de l'esprit
est présenté
comme évidence
de ceux qui sont
héritiers
de la promesse,
ceux qui sont
enfants des dieux.
Ce n'est pas
pour ne pas avoir
les risques
de perdre
cette position,
impossible de perdre,
car base
est sur Christ.
Et donc,
nous sommes en train
de considérer
que pour progresser
dans la foi,
pour nous redresser,
pour avoir
moins d'oscillations
et si jamais
on a eu
des oscillations
notre foi,
comment nous devons
récupérer
le plus tôt possible
la bonne course ?
L'emphase
principale,
c'est celle
qui préserve
tout l'espoir,
c'est de nous demander
est-ce que
les fruits de l'esprit
sont présents
dans ma vie ?
Et si les fruits
de l'esprit
sont présents
dans ma vie,
s'il a déjà été
présent de manière
certaine
à un moment donné
dans mon passé,
c'est sûr
que cet esprit
est encore là
et que je peux
reprendre la course
au plus tôt possible,
mais rélever
de là où j'ai tombé,
je n'ai pas besoin
de recommencer
la course.
Et donc,
c'est fondamental
pour les chrétiens
d'identifier
et de maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'esprit
dans sa vie
afin d'être
de plus en plus
assurés de la foi
et mieux fonctionner
tel que Dieu
nous a fait
pour fonctionner,
mieux chérir
la présence
du Saint-Esprit
en nous.
Il y a deux manières
ou deux étapes
que nous sommes
en train de considérer
pour aborder
ces textes,
c'est que nous devons
avant tout
comprendre
quelle est la nature
du fruit de l'esprit
et les fonctionnements
du fruit de l'esprit,
ces phénomènes,
cet arbre
qui porte du fruit
que nous sommes
à cause de l'habitation
du Saint-Esprit
pour ensuite
considérer
la nature spécifique
de chacune
de ces facettes.
Donc,
verset 22,
les fruits de l'esprit
c'est amour,
joie,
paix,
patience.
Plus tard,
on va prendre le temps
de considérer
chacune de ces facettes
amour,
joie,
paix,
etc.
Et pour l'instant,
nous sommes en train
de considérer
quelle est la nature
ou les fonctionnements
du fruit de l'esprit.
C'est très important.
Donc,
nous avons déjà
à considérer
quatre aspects,
nous sommes en train
de considérer
en cinquième.
Les quatre aspects,
je vais juste vous citer,
c'est de nous rappeler
que c'est un fruit
organique,
c'est-à-dire
qu'il découle naturellement
du Saint-Esprit
qui habite en nous.
Donc,
ce n'est pas quelque chose
que nous pourrions
produire de nous-mêmes.
C'est le Saint-Esprit
qui doit habiter
en quelqu'un
et produire naturellement
comme évidence
de sa présence
et pas comme condition
pour l'avoir.
C'est un fruit spirituel
car c'est le fruit
de l'esprit,
c'est-à-dire
aucun être humain
ne peut
l'avoir naturellement.
Donc,
lorsqu'on nous donne
l'amour,
la joie,
la paix,
c'est clair
que tous les êtres humains
ont la capacité,
même les corrompus,
même les perdus,
de manifester
une certaine mesure
d'amour,
de joie et de paix.
Sauf qu'ici,
si c'est quelque chose
qui ne peut qu'être
produit par le Saint-Esprit,
c'est le fruit de l'esprit,
c'est clair
qu'il s'est lié
à l'œuvre de la rédemption.
C'est lié
à cet amour
que c'est que les chrétiens
qui ont pu connaître
lorsqu'il a tant aimé
le monde
qu'envoyait son Fils
pour mourir
pour ceux
qui croiraient en lui.
et donc la réalité,
c'est qu'ici,
nous sommes devant
un amour,
une joie,
une paix
qui ne peuvent qu'être
engendrées
par Dieu lui-même,
par l'expérience
avec l'Évangile
et qui signifie
à la fin des comptes
cette union vitale
avec Christ
par l'Esprit
ou l'Esprit
qui est appelé
dans la Bible
l'Esprit du Christ
habite en nous
pour former Christ en nous.
Et voilà pourquoi
c'est indivisible.
Le troisième aspect,
c'est le fruit
de l'Esprit
sanglier.
Nous sommes devant
l'intégrité,
l'interdépendance
de toutes ces facettes
qui sont plutôt
en train de présenter
un caractère.
Une personne,
c'est Christ en nous.
Et donc,
tous ces attributs
doivent être ancrés
sur les caractères
parfaitement symétriques
et glorieux du Christ.
Et nous devons
les observer,
toutes ces facettes,
ensemble dans nos vies.
Et bien sûr
qu'il y a dans notre imperfection,
certains de ces facettes
peuvent se manifester
plus que d'autres.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que toutes
doivent être présentes
pour qu'on considère
être une nouvelle créature.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
C'est Christ en nous.
Christ révélé en nous
et Christ manifesté en nous.
C'est ça
les fruits de l'Esprit.
Si vous voulez noter,
les fruits de l'Esprit
sont essentiellement
une union tellement vitale
avec Christ
qui non seulement
produit en nous
une connaissance
expérimentale du Christ
et de l'Évangile,
mais qui produit également
la vie du Christ
dans nos membres
depuis notre être intérieur.
Christ révélé à mon âme,
Christ comme Paul dit,
lorsqu'il a plu à celui
qui m'avait mis à part
d'élévante ma mère,
de révéler son fils
en moi.
La rencontre de Paul
avec Christ,
c'était la manifestation
visible du Christ ressuscité,
sauf que Paul comprend
que Christ n'a pas été révélé
à lui de l'extérieur,
Christ a été révélé en lui
pour que j'annonçasse
la foi entre les païens.
Donc pourquoi
Christ est formé en nous ?
C'est pour qu'on puisse
manifester Christ aux autres.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Oui.
Le quatrième aspect
qu'on a vu,
c'est que ce fruit
est un fruit permanent.
Le Saint-Esprit
est partout présenté
dans la Bible
comme la plus grande promesse
de la Nouvelle-Église
qui ne pourrait
qu'être communiquée
pour habiter en nous,
chez les chrétiens,
chez tous les chrétiens,
lorsque toutes les promesses
du plan de la rédemption
seraient véritablement
et complètement accomplies
à la croix du Christ.
Voilà pourquoi
c'est après la venue du Christ
que le Saint-Esprit
va descendre
pour habiter
chez les chrétiens,
chez tous les chrétiens
et le Saint-Esprit
est donc un saut
et un gage
de notre héritage.
Et le ministère principal
du Saint-Esprit
chez les chrétiens
c'est de nous sanctifier,
c'est de former
Christ en nous.
Voilà pourquoi
la Bible
elle pointe
le Saint-Esprit
comme l'agent souverain
qui opère la régénération,
l'union vitale
avec Christ
et l'agent souverain
qui est là
pour former Christ en nous,
pour révéler Christ en nous
et pour former Christ en nous.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc à partir de là,
si cet esprit
ne pourrait qu'être donné
une fois
que tout était accompli,
lorsqu'il est communiqué
de manière légitime,
authentique en chrétien,
aucune chose
ne peut le révoquer.
Il est appelé
les gages,
l'héritage,
les prémices,
la sémence
qui ne peut pas
s'efflertir,
n'est fanée.
Il est l'espérance
vivante du chrétien.
Donc c'est impossible
que le Saint-Esprit
soit révoqué
de quelqu'un
qui est véritablement chrétien.
Nous pouvons être trompés
et parfois penser
que certains
sont chrétiens,
mais si l'apostasie
devient définitive,
c'est un signe
que cette personne
n'a jamais été
habitation réelle
du Saint-Esprit.
Ils sont sortis de nous,
mais ils n'étaient pas
des nôtres
pour que nous sachions
qu'ils sont tous
entre nous
sont des nôtres.
Explication biblique.
Et donc,
permanent,
c'est lui qui assure
que même si un vrai chrétien
traverse des oscillations
dans la foi,
les pires moments
de notre vie
ne vont pas déterminer
la fin de la course.
Nous pouvons avoir
toute l'espérance
si un jour
on est assuré
qu'on a goûté,
qu'on a manifesté,
même si aujourd'hui
on traverse
beaucoup de difficultés
pour manifester
les fruits de l'esprit,
nous pouvons être sûr
qu'il est là
et qu'il a
toute la puissance nécessaire,
il met à disposition
tous ces dons
dont on a besoin
pour nous redresser.
C'est lui qui opère
les vouloirs
et les faire.
C'est lui qui a commencé
va l'accomplir.
Et le cinquième aspect,
c'est que les fruits
de l'esprit
sont donc cultivables.
Lorsqu'ils nous sommes
perdus
dans nos péchés,
fils et enfants
des colères,
esclaves du péché
et du monde
et même des satans,
c'est impossible
à un non-chrétien
de s'affranchir
lui-même
de cette condition.
Mais Dieu,
riche en miséricorde
à cause du grand amour
avec lequel
il nous a aimés,
il vient vers les chrétiens
et il les sauve,
les régénère,
l'appelle efficacement.
Par la grâce,
vous êtes sauvés,
cela ne vient pas de vous,
c'est un don de Dieu.
Le Saint-Esprit souverain
doit agir
quelque part
de manière unilatérale
pour nous extirper
des ténèbres.
Par contre,
à partir du moment
où on est régénéré,
on est appelé
à répondre
à l'appel de l'Évangile.
Et de manière volontaire
et responsable,
nous devons répondre
positivement,
prendre cette décision
de nous associer
à Christ par la foi
et les déclarer publiquement
par les ordonnances.
À partir du moment
où le Saint-Esprit
a généré la nouvelle vie
et qu'il habite en nous,
il y a
la coopération
entre les croyants
et le Saint-Esprit.
Et dans cette coopération,
nous sommes responsables
et rédévables
par rapport
à la progression
dans la foi.
C'est les Saint-Esprit,
la base,
les fondements
de l'agent majeur
qui pourvoient.
Sans lui,
nous ne pouvons rien faire,
sans Christ.
Et en même temps,
la Bible nous exhorte
constamment
à développer
notre salut
avec vigilance.
Et donc,
le cinquième point,
c'est que
les fruits de l'esprit
sont cultivables.
Et donc,
c'est là
les thèmes
que nous sommes en train
d'aborder.
Les fruits de l'esprit
sont cultivables
et donc,
il exige
de la part des croyants
la responsabilité
et la diligence
pour accueillir
et cultiver
l'influence
de son esprit
afin de maximiser
la manifestation
de son fruit.
Et donc,
comment pouvons-nous
cultiver
ou maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'esprit ?
On a déjà considéré
quelques réponses.
La première,
c'est que pour maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'esprit,
nous devons développer
une soumission
obéissante
ou plutôt
une foi
confiante
aux impératifs
bibliques
pour accueillir
et cultiver
ces influences.
Donc là,
verset 16,
impératif,
marcher selon l'esprit.
Impératif,
marcher.
et vous n'accomplirez
pas les désirs
de la chair.
À nouveau,
vous êtes devant
la tentation,
vous avez pratiqué
récemment
les œuvres
de la chair.
qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire pour régler
chambre des guérisons,
séance
de psychanalyse,
découvrir en fait
quel est l'effet
déclencheur
d'un trauma
que j'ai vécu
à mon enfance.
Pour plus que la prière
soit tellement importante
et qu'elle fait partie
des moyens des grâces
pour faire la bataille
contre la chair,
ici,
c'est un impératif.
Marcher
selon l'esprit.
Vous êtes nouvelle créature,
vous n'êtes plus défini
par votre éducation,
la manière dont vous avez
été élevé,
votre culture,
vous êtes défini
par votre nouvelle identité,
par l'esprit qui habite
en vous,
par votre union vitale
avec Christ
et c'est les caractères
du Christ
qui vous devez manifester.
Toutes les puissances
sont déjà à disposition
à nous d'obéir
de manière soumise.
les sévents de sang
qui disent
si nous vivons
par l'esprit
ou plutôt
dès qu'ils nous vivons
par l'esprit,
marchons aussi
selon l'esprit.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et lorsqu'il peut le dire
les fruits de l'esprit
est amour,
joie,
paix,
patience,
etc.,
nous devons considérer
que c'est une question
de résolution
de manifester
ces vertus
qui sont déjà là.
chapitre 6,
verset 7,
« Ne vous y trompez pas.
Dieu n'est pas moquable. »
Pour être plus littéral
dans la traduction,
on ne se moque pas
des dieux.
Qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire
moquer ou s'émoquer
des dieux ?
C'est par rapport
à la manière
dont un chrétien
est en train
de s'aimer
ou non,
de cultiver
de manifester
ou non
les fruits de l'esprit.
Comment pourrions-nous
nous moquer
de celui
qui,
à ce moment même,
est en train
de soutenir
les battements
de nos cœurs ?
C'est lui
qui est en train
d'empêcher
qu'un anérisme
n'ait pas lieu
pendant qu'on est
en train d'entendre
la prédication.
On ne se moque pas
des dieux.
Et quel est le contexte ?
C'est qu'un homme
aura s'aimé,
il les moissonnera
aussi.
Celui qui s'aime
pour sa chair
moissonnera
de la chair,
la corruption.
Et celui qui s'aime
pour l'esprit,
moissonnera
de l'esprit,
la vie éternelle.
Vous comprenez ?
L'impératif
du Saint-Esprit,
dans sa parole,
cultiver
les fruits
de l'esprit.
Je porte plus
les poires
sur ces saintes
menaces
de la part de Dieu
afin de redresser
les vrais chrétiens.
car la période
de la part de Dieu
envers notre
négligence,
notre tièdeur,
n'est pas un signe
du fait qu'il est
complice
de nos péchés.
Il n'est pas
confondre la patience
de Dieu
avec son agrément.
Donc,
nous devons nous soumettre
aux impératifs bibliques
avec diligence.
Je suis en train
de lire ma Bible
et je ne suis pas
à la recherche
tout simplement
de chercher à savoir
comment Dieu
va changer
les circonstances
pour que je vis
plus confortablement.
Je suis en train
de lire ma Bible
en me permettant
d'être exhorté
par la parole.
Et dès que la Bible
me pousse
dans une direction
où je vois
que ma vie
n'est pas en harmonie,
j'aimerais
le reste vite.
Je cultive,
je saine.
les fruits de l'esprit.
Pour maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'esprit,
nous devons aussi
accueillir et cultiver
ces influences
immédiates et médiées.
Je vous rappelle
tout simplement
que par là,
on a parlé
de ces réveils
que nous pouvons vivre
dans la foi
où c'est comme si
la pluie de Saint-Esprit
tombe sur nous
et la fructification
devient très facile.
Mais ça
ne caractérise pas
toute l'histoire
des hommes de Dieu.
Certaines générations
qui ont vécu ça
soit individuellement
soit collectivement,
pendant une longue période,
c'est là
à faciliter
la manifestation
du Christ
en eux.
Mais cela
ne détermine pas
la vie ordinaire
de tous les croixants.
Nous devons chercher
les réveils,
nous devons chercher
que les Saint-Esprits
nous remplissent
et qu'ils rendent
la fructification facile.
Mais les Saint-Esprits
exercent aussi
des influences intérieures
constamment
chez tous les chrétiens.
et nous devons
être sensibles
à ces inclinations
du Saint-Esprit
à manifester
les fruits de l'Esprit,
à cultiver
les fruits de l'Esprit.
Donc,
ces influences
que les Saint-Esprits
exercent de manière
immédiate envers nous,
ils viennent envers nous,
mais aussi
la manière
dont le Saint-Esprit
nous a déterminés
de manière médiée
par les moyens
des grâces,
Église,
Bible,
prière,
on a consacré
les derniers sermons
sur ça,
je vous encourage
à revenir,
mais c'est les points
des rencontres
avec le Saint-Esprit
qu'il lui-même
a fixé.
Nous devons cultiver
par les moyens
des grâces
cette intimité
avec le Saint-Esprit
qui est la source
du fruit
et en étant
comme cet arbre
de psaume 1
planté près
d'un courant d'eau,
puisez-le.
Nous allons
vers le Saint-Esprit
quelque part
afin que son fruit
se manifeste.
Un point nouveau
pour nous aujourd'hui,
c'est que pour maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'Esprit,
nous devons accueillir
et cultiver
intentionnellement
la formation
du caractère
du Christ
en nous.
C'est juste
pour redoubler
l'emphase
sur le fait
que la manifestation
de ses facettes,
de ses vertus,
c'est la manifestation
des Christ lui-même,
l'amour,
la joie,
la paix,
la patience,
et que lorsque
nous sommes en train
de cultiver
ses vertus,
on ne perd pas
de vue
que ce que nous sommes
en train de cultiver,
c'est le Christ
lui-même
formé en nous,
manifesté en nous.
Chaque facette
du Christ
doit observer
par l'élan
de chacune
de ses facettes
combien aimable
elle est Christ,
combien joyeux
combien il est
la source
de l'amour
suprême
qu'on reçoit
et comment il est
les fondements
de l'amour
chrétien
qu'on doit afficher
aux autres,
comment les Christ
représentent pour moi
ma paix suprême,
au-dessus
de toutes circonstances,
combien Christ
a affiché
la patience
envers nous
et par là
ma habilité
à exercer
la patience
envers les autres,
de quelle manière
je peux considérer
Christ comme bon,
comme parfait,
comme intègre
sans aucune corruption
dans ce qu'il est
et comment il manifeste
sa bénignité
pour les biens
des autres
et donc
j'expérimente
l'adoration
par la contemplation
de la gloire
de Christ
qui nous est présentée
comme totalement aimable
dans son ensemble
et totalement aimable
dans ses parties.
Donc nous devons
cultiver
les fruits de l'esprit
en focalisant
sur Christ.
Utiliser
de manière
très intentionnelle
les moyens
des grâces
et chercher
par tous les pages
des Écritures
pas comment
elles s'adressent
à moi-même
aujourd'hui
mais comment
elles pointent
envers Christ,
comment elles représentent
Christ
dans toute sa gloire
afin que
Christ soit
l'encre
et le fondement
de ma transformation
pour que Christ
soit révélé,
manifesté
à moi
afin qu'il soit
manifesté
à travers moi.
Prendre plaisir
en Christ
pour engendrer
les désirs
d'être
tel que lui
et pour nous donner
la force
dont on a besoin
pour devenir
tel qu'il est.
Deuxième Corinthiens
3,15
nous dit
jusqu'à ces jours
quand on lit Moïse
un voile est jeté
sur leur cœur
les cœurs
des Juifs
non-chrétiens
mais lorsque
les cœurs
se convertissent
au Seigneur
les voiles
sont ôtés
or les Seigneurs
attention
c'est l'Esprit
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
est l'Esprit
et là
où est l'Esprit
du Seigneur
là est la liberté
la liberté
pour vivre
tel qu'il est Christ
tel qu'enfant des dieux
nous tous qui
les visages découverts
contemplons
comme dans un miroir
la gloire du Seigneur
nous sommes transformés
en la même image
des gloires en gloire
comme
par les Seigneurs
l'Esprit
et donc nous voyons clairement
et nous allons nous plonger
davantage dans ces aspects
lorsqu'on va considérer
chacune de ces facettes
en mettant l'encre
à chaque fois
sur comment
elles sont les plus représentées
manifestées en Christ
et plus particulièrement
aujourd'hui
le quatrième point
c'est que pour maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'Esprit
nous devons accueillir
et cultiver
toute la variété
des influences
du Saint-Esprit
il forme
son fruit en nous
et nous devons être
cet arbre
qui fait confiance
à l'eau
qu'il pourvoit
et les vents
qu'il permet
qu'on traverse
on doit être
en train de faire confiance
qu'un étant
raciné
dans les Saint-Esprits
il est non seulement
à nouveau
celui qui habite en nous
mais il est
Dieu
des dieux
la troisième personne
de la Sainte Trinité
Dieu souverain
qui agit en nous
et qui gouverne
toutes les circonstances
à travers nous
et qui a un grand objectif
dans la gouvernance
de l'histoire
le grand objectif
des dieux
dans la gouvernance
de toute l'histoire
c'est de créer
un peuple pour soi
et créer son image
dans son peuple
et c'est ce qu'il est
en train de faire
à travers
les intempéries
à travers les bonnes saisons
comme on a déjà vu
à travers les moments
de réveil
lorsque les influences
intérieures
sont très perceptibles
des fois on a
des privilèges
au début de la foi
où on se sent
vraiment traité
comme un petit bébé
spirituel
et on est très conscient
des influences
très intenses
et fraîches
de son esprit
et Paul il parle
un peu
de cette distinction
entre la petite enfance
et la maturité
spirituelle
mais
le Saint-Esprit
est intéressé
qu'on soit toujours
comme des enfants
c'est à dire confiant
et dépendant
du Christ
mais pas toujours
infantile
et donc
envers la maturité
même lorsque
ces influences
intérieures
ne sont pas
très perceptibles
il nous permet
que nos disciplines
spirituelles
nos lettures bibliques
notre diligence
à rester dans notre poste
soient aussi
des moyens de grâce
qui nous conduisent
à plus de maturité
mais il y a des périodes
où ces disciplines
spirituelles
sont très fluides
on lit avec hâte
les écritures
on prie avec
beaucoup de volonté
mais c'est pas toujours
comme ça
des fois on a la chance
d'avoir
un apôtre Paul
dans nos vies
bien sûr qu'on a plus
d'apôtre aujourd'hui
mais
un homme rempli
de Saint-Esprit
qui aime énormément
notre église
qui connaît très bien
les écritures
ces représentants
éveillés du Christ
peut-être
notre père
notre mère
un frère de la famille
un pasteur
qui sera à chaque fois
utilisé par Dieu
pour exercer
cette influence
du Saint-Esprit
envers nous
mais l'intérêt des dieux
c'est pas
qu'on vit toujours
une fois
dans une dépendance
en direct
et donc c'est clair
que quand on voit
ces circonstances
favorables
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
semble siffler
favorablement
pour la production
du fruit
je pense que nous tous
aimerions
dépendre surtout
et qu'il y ait
de ses moyens
par contre
il est de l'intérêt
du Saint-Esprit
de cultiver
la production
du fruit
en nous
à travers
les mauvais temps
les intempéries
à travers
la manière
dont parfois
comme les Christ
dit au Père
attends Seigneur
je vais encore
nettoyer les terrains
renverser les terrains
découper
quelques branches
pour voir
si les fruits
seront produits
et les problèmes
c'est que
dans la génération
a été tellement
gâché
par les faux prophètes
de la théologie
de la prospérité
qui donne l'impression
!
qu'après la conversion
c'est la vie en rose
mais après la conversion
Dieu nous donne
une armure
c'est une bataille
spirituelle affreuse
et c'est surtout
par ces moyens
que la piété
non seulement
doit être vécue
à contre-courant
mais la piété
sera renforcée
tout comme
les Christ
a dû vivre
cette piété
sous persécution
sous opposition
la Bible nous enseigne
que la prospérité
du fruit de l'esprit
chez nous
est davantage développée
dans les circonstances
difficiles
donc au lieu
de douter
de l'amour
de Dieu
ou de sa
toute puissance
lorsque nous traversons
des moments difficiles
on devrait dire
comme disait
Spurgeon
j'ai appris
à aimer
les vagues
qui me jettent
contre les rochers
des âges
sachant que
c'est notamment
par là
dans les difficultés
que nous ne trouverons
pas
des excuses
pour justifier
un comportement
plus similaire
au diable
qu'aux anges
au contraire
c'est de nous rappeler
que selon
l'enseignement
de la Bible
depuis l'Ancien Testament
et surtout
les nouveaux
l'un des moyens
les plus efficaces
d'agendrer
les fruits de l'esprit
en nous
c'est de nous faire
traverser fidèlement
les tribulations
en ce cours
davantage bien présent
au moment
d'angoisse
donc les intempéries
des Galates
sont évidentes
c'est
ce qu'Paul
est en train
d'exiger
de leur comportement
dans cette lettre
c'est à dire
manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
marcher dans l'esprit
et lorsqu'il va
donner les raisons
ou lorsqu'il nous
est devant
les contextes
nous ne sommes pas
en train de trouver
car il n'y a rien
qui vous manque
dans un niveau
matériel
car vous avez
la chance
de vivre
dans une situation
politique
où tout est favorable
à l'évangile
car vos vies
sont très bien ordonnées
et vous êtes en train
de satisfaire
toutes les demandes
physiques
respecter votre bien-être
et les conforts
de vos vies
non c'est
une église
en pleine division
attaquée par des hérésies
sous menace
des persécutions
désillusion
des plusieurs croyants
car ils sont déjà
en train de s'attaquer
de se mordre
de se dévorer
et Paul est en train
de dire
n'attendez pas
que les circonstances
s'améliorent
soit vous-même
la solution
le soleil
qui va éclater
sur ces ténèbres
soit vous-même
les Christs
au milieu des ténèbres
flambeaux
pour cette génération
donc les Galates
sont appelées
à accueillir
et cultiver
les fruits de l'esprit
dans les mauvaises saisons
cela peut
sembler contre-intuitive
ça ne devrait pas l'être
les hommes les plus matures
les femmes les plus matures
dans la foi
sont retrouvés
avec ceux
qui sont présentés par Paul
en hébreu chapitre 11
les héros
de la foi
toujours à contre-courant
toujours sous persécution
en manifestant
les fruits de l'esprit
les parallèles
pour ces textes
lorsqu'on pense
aux fruits de l'esprit
c'est Ephésiens
chapitre 5
que je vous appelle
à ouvrir avec moi
pour remarquer
les similarités
je lirai quelques versets
à partir du verset 1
soyez donc
les imitateurs
des dieux
manifester les fruits de l'esprit
c'est d'être
un imitateur des dieux
puisque vous êtes
ces enfants bien aimés
c'est à dire
si vous êtes enfant
manifester les caractéristiques
de votre père
et vivez dans l'amour
remarquez bien
les facettes
du fruit de l'esprit
l'amour en suivant
l'exemple du Christ
donc c'est ancré
sur Christ
qui nous a aimés
donc c'est un amour
qui dépend
de l'expérience
et la connaissance
de l'amour
salvatrice du Christ
salvateur du Christ
et qui s'est donné
lui-même pour nous
comme une offrande
et un sacrifice
dont l'odeur
est agréable à Dieu
c'est un amour
sacrificiel
c'est pas un amour
lorsque les choses sont faciles
c'est un amour
tel que l'est Christ
que l'immoralité sexuelle
et donc là
ce sont plutôt
les parallèles
pour les œuvres
de la chair
l'immoralité sexuelle
l'impureté
sous toutes ses formes
où la soif des possédés
ne soit même pas
mentionnée parmi vous
comme il convient
à des saints
la manière
la plus radicale
de traiter ces problèmes
c'est pas de faire
des séries
des prédications
sur ces thèmes
c'est d'être
plutôt focalisé
dans la cultivation
du fruit de l'esprit
et sortir radicalement
sans même pas mentionner
à ces choses
s'il y a des personnes
qui traversent
des problèmes
personnels
envers ces choses
c'est important
d'aller chercher
de l'aide
avec les pasteurs
les plus matures
dans la foi
mais c'est pas toujours
quelque chose
doit être traité
en collectif
car pour ceux
qui sont pas en train
de traverser
ces tentations
peuvent découvrir
la tentation
par le désir
d'être toujours
en train de traiter
des polémiques
sur internet
sur les églises
en parlant
des choses
qui va chère
a beaucoup
d'intérêt
à savoir
donc ici
c'est intéressant
même pas mentionné
entre vous
vous le savez bien
en effet
aucune
aucun pardon
être immoral
impur
ou toujours
désireux
de posséder plus
c'est
c'est à dire
l'idolâtre
n'a d'héritage
dans les royaumes
des Christ
et des dieux
question d'héritage
manifestation
d'être un enfant
c'est pas une condition
que personne
ne vous trompe
par des paroles
sans fondement
car c'est pour cela
que la colère
des dieux vient
sur les hommes
rebelles
là il y a un point
qui est lié
à la notion
de fidélité
au vrai évangile
et c'est cette
n'ayez donc
aucune part avec eux
car si autrefois
vous étiez ténèbres
maintenant vous êtes
lumière dans les seigneurs
conduisez-vous
impératif
comme des enfants
des lumières
et voilà l'introduction
récénèbres
les fruits de l'esprit
consistent en effet
dans toute forme
des bontés
des justices
et des vérités
c'est 10
quelle vie
est la vie
qui cultive dans la pratique
les fruits de l'esprit
discernez ce qui est agréable
au seigneur
et ne participez pas
aux œuvres stériles
des ténèbres
mais démasquez-le
plutôt
en effet
c'est que ces hommes
font en secret
il est même honteux
d'en parler
mais tout est démasqué
par la lumière
qui est démasqué
apparaît clairement
car tout ce qui apparaît
ainsi est lumière
c'est pourquoi
il a dit
réveille-toi
qui dort
possiblement aussi
un croyant
dans sa tièdeur
réveille-toi
d'entre les morts
et Christ éclaira
faites donc bien attention
à la façon
dont vous vous conduisez
impératif
ne vous comportez pas
comme des fous
mais comme des sages
attention
c'est pas
il n'y a aucune
marge ici
pour un traitement
des victimisations
vers soi-même
comme si on était des malades
si on est vraiment chrétien
c'est un impératif
rachetez les temps
faites un bon emploi de temps
car les jours sont mauvais
c'est-à-dire
les jours
sont mauvais
ce qui caractérise
la vie
de tous les chrétiens
c'est la mauvaise saison
les mauvaises saisons
n'ont pas la capacité
de supprimer
la capacité
que les chrétiens
ont
de retrouver réfuges
dans la cité céleste
à n'importe quel moment
nos vies
ne sont pas marquées
par les manques
d'amour
joie
paix
car nous sommes exposés
à la persécution
à la difficulté
nos vies
sont marquées
par amour
paix
joie
car notre amour
paix
et notre joie
sont
dans notre ordre
que l'ordre
de ce monde
ne soyez pas stupides
mais comprenez
quelle est la volonté
du Seigneur
ne vous inivrez pas
devant
cela amène à la débauche
soyez au contraire
remplis de l'esprit
vous voyez le parallèle
entre les textes
c'était surtout
pour qu'on soit convaincu
que la vie chrétienne
sera marquée
beaucoup plus
par les intempérés
nous devons
être très reconnaissants
à Dieu
si on traverse
des périodes
favorables
des paix
où tout semble
aller bien
tout semble
être équilibré
mais doutons
comme Weisley
qui se demandait
Seigneur
je viens de prêcher
l'évangile
des multitudes
des personnes
sont venues
m'écouter
mais ta parole
m'est dit
que tous ceux
qui veulent
mener en vie
piole
seront persécutés
et moi
je ne me sens pas
persécuté
c'est au moment
de ma vie
et là
il reçoit
une pierre
sur sa tête
et là
il est en paix
et il continue
et donc
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
nous devons
toucher l'allièrement
aux circonstances
de ces vies
au moment
où les choses
nous sont très favorables
mais toujours
nous accrocher
à ces choses
avec
un accrochage
lâche
si on peut dire
comme ça
prédisposé
à rénoncer
afin de progresser
dans la direction
qui va augmenter
la révélation
du Christ en nous
et la révélation
et donc
le Saint-Esprit
il utilise
trois moyens
aux trois types
d'intempéries
pour maximiser
la production
de son fruit
en nous
au moins trois
d'entre les plus
importants
le premier
c'est la discipline
donc la lettre
des Galates
heureusement
on n'a pas
une deuxième lettre
pour les commentaristes
pour les théologiens
c'est un signe
que cette église
est corrigée
c'est pas comme
les correntiens
qui ont été
tellement durs
et rebelles
que Paul a dû
rédiger une autre lettre
mais pour ce qui
concerne les Galates
pour plus
que l'apôtre Paul
soit très dur
dans les exhortations
et les corrections
qu'il fait
ça semble
avoir été
très efficace
on a vu
les passages
où cette correction
est manifestée
avec un cœur
paternel
spirituel
car l'apôtre Paul
il dit
qu'il a encore
les douleurs
d'enfantement
pour former
Christ
en eux
vous êtes avec moi ?
oui!
!
pour ses fils
supporter
les châtiments
c'est comme
des fils
que Dieu
vous traite
car
quels sont les fils
qu'un père
ne châtie pas
mais si vous êtes
exempts
du châtiment
auquel
tous
on part
vous êtes donc
des enfants
illégitimes
et non des fils
d'ailleurs
puisque nos pères
selon la chair
nous ont châtiés
et que nous
les avons respectés
n'aiderons-nous pas
à bien plus forte raison
nous soumettre
au père des esprits
pour avoir la vie
nos pères
nous châtiaient
pour un peu
des jours
comme il est trouvé bon
mais Dieu nous châtie
pour notre bien
afin
attention
que nous
participions
à sa sainteté
pour qu'on fonctionne
comme ses enfants
et il est vrai
que tout châtiment
semble d'abord
un sujet de tristesse
et non des joies
mais il produit
plus tard
pour ceux qui ont été
ainsi exercés
en fruits paisibles
des justices
la discipline
souveraine
du Saint-Esprit
agit
par ses influences
internes
la discipline
agit
à travers sa parole
la prédication
et les conseils
qu'on reçoit
mais c'est clair
que
la discipline
dont l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de parler ici
c'est une discipline
qui est clairement
ressentie dans la vie
des difficultés
qu'on traverse
des tribulations
des situations graves
comme dit Cécilius
Dieu
il murmure
à nos oreilles
lorsqu'on est en train
de traverser
par des moments
de plaisir
on est un peu gêné là
il y a les choses
qui vont bien
mais même
en traversant
des choses bien
on sent
qu'il Dieu
est en train
de déjeuner
car on sait
qu'il y a un péché
qu'il faut traiter
il parle
il murmure
quand on est en train
de traverser
les plaisirs
il nous parle
plus fort
à travers
notre conscience
mais il crie
à haute voix
à travers
notre douleur
il dit
les tribulations
sont les mégaphones
pour réveiller
nos oreilles sourdes
des péchés
domestiqués
avec lesquels
on traîne
longtemps
la patience
des dieux
n'est pas synonyme
de son agrément
nous sommes
si nous sommes
enfants des dieux
en train de nous exposer
nous rendre vulnérables
à ces disciplines
Ephésiens 4
30 nous dit
n'attristez pas
les saint esprit
des dieux
par lesquels
vous avez été
scellés
pour les jours
de la rédemption
comment nous pouvons
attrister
les saint esprit
qui est toute amertume
toute animosité
toute colère
toute clameur
toute calomnie
et toute espèce
de méchanceté
disparaissent
au milieu de vous
soyez bons
les uns vers les autres
compatissant
vous pardonnant
réciproquement
comme Dieu
vous a pardonné
en Christ
quelle est la plus
grande préoccupation
de celui
qui a été scellé
par l'esprit
de Christ
être moins exposé
à ses influences
c'est pas
que les saint esprit
puissent se retirer
comme c'était
dans la période
dans le Saint Testament
lorsque David
va mentionner cela
car c'était
un type messianique
du Christ
sur lequel
l'onction
du saint esprit
reposait
le saint esprit
qui s'est retiré
des saûts
pour venir
accompagner David
dans son ministère
mais attrister
le saint esprit
s'est dépassé
d'une coopération
favorable
où il exerce
ses influences
content vers nous
et nous accueillons
ses influences
content avec lui
et nous passons
au terrain
de l'ennemi
en gênant
celui qui habite
en nous
en attristant
celui qui habite
en nous
et l'un des recours
que le saint esprit
là
c'est ce qui était
la terreur
des puritans
la nuit obscure
de l'âme
avoir de moins en moins
la sensibilité
aux affections religieuses
à la lecture biblique
à la prière
à cause
de la
à cause du fait
qu'on a perduré
dans un péché
par rapport
auquel
le saint esprit
pendant
tous les longs
de chemin
vous exhortait
quand est-ce
qu'on va
pouvoir
renouveler
ces festants
de l'âme
de la communion
intime
avec le saint esprit
si ça dépend
de lui
et pour un chrétien
qui a déjà goûté
cette intimité
avec Dieu
avec le saint esprit
il n'y a aucune idée
plus ténébreuse
qu'il y ait de perdre
cette sensibilité
David
quand il a péché
très grave
le psaume 51
nous enseigne
qu'il était
prédisposé
à souffrir
ce qu'il fallait souffrir
lave-moi
complètement
de mon iniquité
et purifie-moi
de mon péché
car je reconnais
mes transgressions
et mon péché
est constamment
devant moi
j'ai péché
contre toi seul
et j'ai fait
ce qui a mal
à tes yeux
en sorte que
tu seras juste
dans ta sentence
sans réproche
dans ton jugement
David
il savait
s'émettre
dans les mains
de Dieu
pour être puni
pour être corrigé
Seigneur
si ta discipline
sera plus efficace
qui est mon
inconstance
qui est ma négligence
amène ta discipline
fais-moi
sans
les chrétiens
il n'est pas
si tant
préoccupé
l'idée
c'est qu'il
ne se sent jamais
suffisamment
puni
par un péché
même s'il doit
savoir
qu'en Christ
tout est puni
mais sa préoccupation
n'est pas
si tant
que les circonstances
changent
lorsqu'il
la sous-discipline
il veut
ne pas perdre
nouveau
et c'est quatorze
il dit
rends-moi
la joie
de ton salut
et qu'en esprit
de bonne volonté
me soutienne
et donc
Dieu fait
usage
de la discipline
pour nous éveiller
éveiller
à restaurer
les trésors
suprêmes
que nous avons
les trésors
suprêmes
c'est cette intimité
avec le Saint-Esprit
c'est
de manifester
la vie des dieux
dans nos membres
et s'il faut
tout perdre
pour restaurer ça
un chrétien
est bien disposé
à embrasser
la discipline
des dieux
les choses sont
difficiles
particulièrement
de plus en plus
difficiles
quelles questions
on doit se poser
examiner nos cœurs
Seigneur
aide-moi
à voir
si je trouve
des fautes
qui me sont cachées
parfois
ou quelles sont
les fautes
que je manque
la préoccupation
du chrétien
n'est pas citant
tout simplement
de se dire
je regarde
les œuvres
de la chair
et je vois
qu'elles ne sont pas
très présentes
dans ma vie
on est content
immoralité sexuelle
idolâtrie
peut-être pas
une personne
très agressive
des accès
de colère
la préoccupation
du chrétien
n'est pas
une envie
de ne pas
se porter
de manière
similaire au diable
il doit prendre
les fruits de l'esprit
et se demander
est-ce que je suis
en train
de représenter
Christ
on pourrait
s'attendre
qu'une personne
sous-discipline
soit en train
de pratiquer
les œuvres de la chair
mais une personne
sous-discipline
peut être en train
d'être corrigée
pour ne pas manifester
davantage
les fruits de l'esprit
qu'est-ce que Dieu
peut être en train
de crier
nous sommes
possiblement
sous-discipline
il faut être
intentionnel
et chercher
dans les fruits
de l'esprit
quelles sont
les facettes
manquantes
comment nous
pouvons davantage
les manifester
le Saint-Esprit
utilise aussi
non seulement
la discipline
mais il utilise
également
les tribulations
ni toute difficulté
qu'on traverse
est conséquence
ou fruit
d'un péché particulier
que Dieu vise
à traiter
et c'est clair
que cette discipline
de Dieu
pour corriger
nos péchés
ne sont pas toujours
les premiers recours
Dieu est patient
gracieux
il nous enseigne
comment pratiquer
la discipline
de l'Église
basée sur la manière
dont il nous traite
compatissons
mais c'est vrai
qu'il fait usage
même des difficultés
de la vie
pour produire
les fruits
de l'esprit
en nous
béni soit les Pères
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
qui selon sa grande
miséricorde
nous a régénérés
pour une espérance
vivante
cette espérance vivante
est des Saint-Esprit
par la résurrection
de Jésus Christ
d'entre les morts
pour un héritage
qui ne peut se corrompre
ni soulier
ni flertrir
lesquels vous a réservés
dans les cieux
à vous
qui par la justice
pardon
par la puissance
des dieux
êtes gardés
par la foi
pour les saluts
prêts à être révélés
dans les derniers temps
c'est là
ce qui fait votre joie
quoique maintenant
puisqu'il est faux
vous soyez attristés
pour un peu de temps
par des diverses épreuves
afin qu'il est preuve
de votre foi
plus précieuse
qui est l'or périssable
qui cependant
est éprouvé
par les feux
est pour résultat
la louange
la gloire
l'honneur
lorsque Jésus Christ
apparaîtra
lui qui vous aimez
sans l'avoir vu
en qui vous croyez
sans les voir encore
vous réjouissant
d'une joie ineffable
et glorieuse
dans quelles circonstances
nous avons accès
à la joie ineffable
et glorieuse
comme il faut
c'est nécessaire
de travailler
par des diverses épreuves
pour que notre foi
soit épurée
par les feux
et les fruits
de l'esprit
soient développés
en nous
l'amour
de Dieu
la joie
de quelle manière
nos tribulations
ont joué
pour qu'on puisse
attester
en plein milieu
des pires tribulations
de nos vies
que Dieu était bien présent
que son amour
n'a pas manqué
que ses soins
n'ont pas manqué
que c'était notamment
dans ces circonstances
les plus difficiles
où on a vécu
nos meilleurs moments
avec Dieu
et comment
ces épreuves
qu'on a traversées
nous ont préparés
pour traverser
des nouvelles épreuves
et même si c'était effrayant
par certains aspects
on était rassurés
que ça serait
une nouvelle aventure
qu'il serait avec nous
qu'on sortirait
plus sans
Romain 5
la même chose
nous est enseigné
étant donc justifié
par la foi
nous avons la paix
avec Dieu
par notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
à qui nous devons
d'avoir eu
par la foi
accès à cette grâce
dans laquelle
nous démarrons fermes
et nous nous glorifions
dans l'espérance
de la gloire des dieux
bien plus
nous nous glorifions
même des afflictions
sachant que l'affliction
produit la persévérance
la persévérance
la victoire dans l'épreuve
et cette victoire
l'espérance
or l'espérance
n'est trompée point
c'est à dire
sans cette espérance
trouvée au milieu
de la tribulation
nous n'expérimenterons pas
cette espérance
qui n'est trompée point
parce que l'amour
des dieux
est répandu
dans nos cœurs
par les saints esprits
qui nous a été donné
surtout au milieu
des tribulations
et des épreuves
et donc nous
devons apprendre
à embrasser
cette manière
par laquelle
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
nous a toujours enseigné
que les chrétiens
seraient fortifiés
pour produire
les fruits de l'esprit
à travers les tribulations
c'est l'une des choses
que je pense
les plus urgentes
à corriger
dans la conception
des sanctifications
dans la vie chrétienne
ce qui fait la différence
entre un chrétien réel
et un non-chrétien
c'est sa constance
car tout ce qu'il y a
autour de nous
est en constant
la seule constance
dans nos vies
c'est la présence
des dieux en nous
et la manifestation
de son caractère
les chrétiens sont appelés
à être image des dieux
à manifester Christ
de manière
naturelle
et positive
mais aussi
et c'est ça
qui fait la différence
de manière réactive
aimer ceux qui nous persécutent
aimer nos ennemis
prier pour ceux
qui nous persécutent
sont appelés
à ne pas répondre
les mal avec mal
mais surmonter
les mal avec les biens
donc un chrétien
ne peut pas être
susceptible
aux intempéries
les vents
sifflent plus fort
contre l'arbre
l'arbre
fait pousser davantage
les racines
envers les courants d'eau
le troisième aspect
il faut que je fasse
de manière assez courte
mais
c'est l'engagement
missionnaire
tout simplement
la Bible
elle enseigne partout
que l'engagement
missionnaire
la vie pieuse
l'avancement
de l'évangile
sera toujours
marqué
par l'opposition
quand on lit
la lettre
des Paul aux Galates
on voit un homme
qui a placardé
les Christs
comme crucifié
à cette église
avec l'aide
du Saint-Esprit
une prédication
honorée
par la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
et lorsqu'il présentait
les Christs
par la prédication
les personnes
ont eu une expérience
comme si les Christs
étaient présents
placardés
devant eux
avez-vous reçu
les Saint-Esprit
par les œuvres
de la loi
par des rites
religieux
par l'eau bénie
ou l'huile
qui a oint
un instrument
ou par vos séances
des fréquentations
du mercredi
des réveils
non
par la prédication
de la foi
les Saint-Esprit
vous a été communiqué
vous êtes né de nouveau
vous avez reçu
les Saint-Esprit
vous avez produit
vous avez commencé bien
vous couriez bien
c'est comme ça
la génèse de cette église
l'évangile étant prêché
cette église
était née
et pensons à Paul
qui a produit
par la grâce de Dieu
donc Dieu a produit
à travers
les ministères de Paul
la naissance
de cette église
un homme des dieux
rempli de Saint-Esprit
proclamant la vérité
avec fidélité
s'exposant à la persécution
qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit
dans Galates
que lorsqu'il a été
pour la première fois
au milieu d'eux
il était défiguré
battu
on a cru qu'il était
déjà mort
et les Galates
l'ont traité
Paul comme
un ange
comme Christ
lui-même
pourquoi
car Paul
lorsqu'il avançait
pour prêcher
l'évangile
contre la persécution
il était non seulement
en train de porter
les messages du Christ
il était en train
de manifester
Christ dans ses membres
les plus nous sommes
engagés
peu importe
quelle soit
l'opposition
au travail
à l'université
à l'école
nous avons tous
un même appel
être témoin
c'est le seul appel
qui fait du sang
c'est la seule chose
qu'on peut faire
encore dans cette vie
c'est la seule raison
pour laquelle
Dieu nous maintient
de ce monde
nous pouvons avoir
tous des vocations
secondaires différentes
mais nous devrions
tous faire face
à nos métiers
commentaire en missionnaire
si vous voulez manifester
les fruits du Saint-Esprit
dans vos vies
vous devez prendre conscience
que la plus grande
manifestation
d'amour
dans cette dimension
c'est prêcher l'évangile
c'est partager l'évangile
la plus grande
manifestation
des joies
c'est de partager
la bonne nouvelle
la promotion
de la paix
ne passe pas
par la politique
et par la réconciliation
avec Dieu
en Christ
la compréhension
de ce qui est
véritablement
la patience
c'est d'apprendre
comment Dieu
nous a traités
malgré nous
et donc
non seulement
c'est
la manifestation
du Christ
et de son évangile
lorsqu'on manifeste
les fruits de l'esprit
en proclamant
en partageant la vérité
mais ce sont
les vertus
dont on a
le plus besoin
pour évangéliser
un monde rébelle
un monde d'opposition
quelqu'un
mettraite
avec agressivité
avec persécution
on peut perdre
l'emploi
être rénoncé
à une promotion
mais c'est
en tombant
devant les mondes
que nous allons
promouvoir
leur vie
et leur salut
devant Dieu
Etienne
rempli
de Saint-Esprit
proclame
la vérité
de l'évangile
en acte 7
la Bible va
mettre en emphase
qu'il était rempli
de Saint-Esprit
voilà pourquoi
il a pu manifester
de la manière
la plus belle possible
les fruits de l'esprit
même
en étant
lapidé
et vers la fin
c'est la mort
la plus similaire
à celle du Christ
qu'on va retrouver
dans le Nouveau Testament
Père
ne les impute pas
ses péchés
l'apôtre Paul
la même chose
et c'est clair
que
si nous nous rappelons
que la paix
de Dieu
c'est pour que
tous les croyants
soient investis
bien sûr que
surtout
les ministres
de l'évangile
qui sont appelés
sont appelés
à vivre
cette expérience
de l'apôtre Paul
je vous ai appelé
pour que vous alliez
et que vous portiez
beaucoup de fruits
T.C. Wright
il exhorte
les jeunes chrétiens
en disant
pendant longtemps
l'histoire de l'église
n'avait pas les ressources
pour envoyer les missionnaires
partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui
les problèmes
criants
c'est que l'église
dispose des ressources
mais il n'y a pas
plus de personnes
prédisposées à elles
et c'est des manières
assez mathématiques
car
toutes les nations
doivent entendre l'évangile
et nous savons
qu'il y a des nations
qui n'ont pas encore
été touchées par l'évangile
et nous devons
être prédisposés
à promouvoir
tout pouvoir
m'a été donné
dans les ciels
et sur la terre
allez fête
des disciples
de toutes les nations
baptisant au nom du Père
du Fils et du Saint-Esprit
enseigne-leur
à observer
tout ce que j'ai prescrit
et voici
je suis avec vous
tous les jours
jusqu'à la fin du monde
si vous voulez
avoir des nouvelles
expériences
avec la présence
du Christ
soyez engagés
avec la mission
centrale du Christ
même devant
toute opposition terrestre
je vous encourage
à lire après
2 Corinthiens 4
parce qu'il peut
vous parler
de toutes les difficultés
qu'il traverse
la mort
en agissant
dans leur corps
dans leurs membres
mortels
et en même temps
promouvant la vie
parce que Paul va dire
que sa vie
était Christ
mourir était en gant
mais
s'il avait du fruit
pour les ministères
il préférait
il ne savait pas
ce qu'il préférait
car le seul sens
qu'il a pour cette vie
c'est qu'il nous atteint
glorieux
et merveilleux
infiniment supérieur
à tout ce que nous
pouvons vivre ici bas
la seule manière
de nous enrichir
davantage
pour les paradis
c'est en investissant
dans les saluts des âmes
Philippiens chapitre 1
et surtout
quand on arrive
en acte
chapitre 20
où Paul va dire
je ne considère
en rien
ma vie
qu'en précieuse
pour moi-même
Philippiens
il est emprisonné
il dit
sachez qu'avant tout
les souffrances
que je traverse
ma prison
c'est une occasion
pour partager l'évangile
à toute la garde romaine
qu'importe
il dit
si je meurs
si je pars
l'important
c'est que Christ
soit prêché
je suis convaincu
que la grande majorité
des chrétiens
ne manifestent pas
les fruits
de son esprit
avec plus de force
avec plus de puissance
car ils ne sont pas
à leur poste
ils ne sont pas actifs
dans la vie de l'église
pour faire des disciples
pour partager l'évangile
car ça renouvelle
l'essence
des rédivabilités
devant Dieu
si je vais
vers mon travail
avec une identité
camuflée
je peux me mêler
à leurs péchés
me comporter
comme ils se portent
en pensant
que ça peut
ne pas avoir
un impact
sur ma foi
ou sur leur salut
si je viens
voir vers mon travail
avec la conviction
que je suis un représentant
du Christ
pour manifester
le Christ
pour sauver
ces personnes
c'est un autre niveau
d'amour
de patience
de fidélité
d'intégrité
travailler avec excellence
non pour les hommes
mais pour Dieu
fonctionner
comme Jésus a dit
comme celle de la terre
pour pouvoir fonctionner
comme lumière du monde
si je dois
conduire
en étude
avec une
soeur
dans la foi
une femme
plus mature
dans la foi
et je m'engage
à faire un discipula
si je suis un homme
et je vais conduire
un autre jeune
ou un petit groupe
de maison
ça va me forcer
à me plonger davantage
dans les écritures
à être plus rélivable
devant Dieu
à chercher la puissance
de Dieu
pour voir la transformation
dans la vie
de mon frère
le plus on s'engage
là on devrait s'engager
le plus on a
cette expérience
de progresser
dans la fraîcheur
de la présence du Christ
en nous
par son esprit
et dans la manifestation
du fruit de l'esprit
en nous
envers les autres
donc c'est clair
que davantage
et d'habitude
on entend parler
quand on voit
les arguments
de toutes les difficultés
qui comprennent
les ministères
se livrer à temps
pour les ministères
ou même s'engager
dans un ministère
dans une société
qui s'oppose
il suffit de penser
à nos frères
en Syrie
il suffit d'élier
les nouveaux testaments
car on n'a jamais
été présenté
par la Bible
avec d'autres paramètres
des sociétés
l'évangile va avancer
nous devons être engagés
et le fruit de l'esprit
sera maximisé
lorsqu'on sera engagé
dans la promotion
de l'évangile
malgré l'opposition
Amen